PEGGY SCOTT:
It's from the publisher
of The Christian Advocate.
Why is he writing you?
He wants to meet.
Are you enjoying
your stay in New York?
I'd love to tell you
all about it.
Who'd object to that?
Oh, Henry, Henry,
must you live on in your child?
Can you not set her free
for pity's sake?
Having a new rail station
in this city isn't as popular
as we'd hoped it might be.
(CHUCKLING)
BERTHA RUSSELL:
Mrs. Morris is leaving.
GEORGE RUSSELL: I thought
you were honorable men.
Not too honorable
to miss the chance
of a fast buck, of course.
But not greedy, dirty thieves!
Mr. Russell...
GEORGE: Would you have tried
to get the better of me?
How could I allow that
to go unpunished?